I'm a lesbian I'm a lesbian I'm a
lesbian I'm a lesbian I'm a lesbian I'm
a lesbian I'm a
[Music]
lesbian hi I'm Mars and I went to an old
girl school for 5 years so I feel like
that's pretty self-explanatory uh hi I'm
Giana um I feel like my appearance is an
upsid to be honest hi my name is Lisa my
girlfriend was the first time I ever
stood up for myself hi my name is Iris
and I uh eat what I have
how would you eat uh my name's Maya and
I go to Berkeley and I'm a film and
media student uh my name's Claire I've
been a relationship with the most
beautiful woman my girlfriend for 2 and
a half years officially yesterday ni my
name is Mara and I've been married since
January
[Music]
31st I voted her out just because she
was the straightest
looking this the second we walked in I
looked at everybody's outfits and I feel
like everyone just kind of had like a
more eccentric vibe to their outfit
whereas Mara was just wearing shorts and
a
t-shirt a y'all it is not me though for
real she just talks a little bit too
much and it feels like she's
overcompensating I'm letting y'all know
right now is not me y'all will see my
girl outside it's letting y'all know
it's probably the nails it's probably
the hair it's probably the lashes the
makeup the gloss so let's be real you
would never guess to start us off um who
is everybody's childhood crush or like
gay Awakening have you guys seen Lizzie
MaGuire or you
Miranda okay Miss honey was a big one
for Matilda but also Amanda bin and
specifically in Sydney White I don't
remember my childhood one but like sixth
grade was RuPaul's Drag Race Ador Delano
that was my her and drag I don't know
like I don't know I wasn't exposed to
much as a kid but Rooney Mara from Carol
if you guys have seen that movie H oh my
God honestly my first one's not like a
movie character or like a TV show
character it's a bank teller that I went
to go see with my dad and I think he was
using me as his wingman but I had my own
idea of what was going on you a little
bit in your diary little bit there was
this girl in my like fourth grade class
I want to say one time she was standing
in front of me at the teacher's desk and
I just got like super close to her she
used to bully me in that grade by the
way and I stood like super close to her
and I was like oh my God but I was in
Catholic school at the time so I was
like oh no and then stopped thinking
about it for like 3 years I have a
question what would you guys say like
are you guys like top bottom like switch
fem mask like what what what do you
identify within like the lesbian realm
um verse switch um uh I'm definitely fem
I would say not I I go hyper fem when I
go out I love makeup and dressing up and
costumes in that way I would say I'm
switch but also I feel like no offense
to you cute Jen's ears I feel like the
mask fem thing is a little bit more
genen Z than when I was growing up and
coming out it wasn't really discussed
those terms didn't even exist then um so
I think I kind of my wife and I both are
a little bit of both I am the oldest in
the group so I felt like maybe that
would set me behind because I don't know
all the lingo in The Tick Tock language
yeah I'd say I'm more like mask top as
you can tell um
but yeah I would say I mean I like to
bottom you know whatever uh but I do
become more like feminine when I'm like
in the club
of feels to like it is it's and it like
kind of like you know crosses the line
and like bends line a little bit yeah
it's a spectrum and we can play with it
100% I think that would be uh a bottom
as people sorry so I'm not used to
saying these things aloud if you can
tell despite that really really love
wearing stuff that's more Mas like suits
and ties are what I like to wear I'm
sorry Grandma but I'm
definitely um I definitely verse and I
feel like my appearance definitely leans
more feminine um but in relationships
I'm typically the more masked person
yeah um I'm definitely a switch and I
think my style reflects that like pretty
stereotypically sometimes I dress like a
little fairy sometimes I dress like a
12-year-old boy 12-year-old boy heavy
when I'm at work um me right now
literally how was everybody's family and
friends when you guys came out like was
it difficult was it I think I can take
this one um so the first time I brought
it up uh I did it at dinner over I
believe Christmas break uh the first
thing I I knew they was going to have a
bad response cuz I grew up in an Asian
household that was like pretty
traditional conservative and my mom
first thing she said was that uh like
something about like conversion therapy
stuff like grow out of it and I would
need to find a husband um eventually and
still to this day she called my uh
girlfriend of 5 years oh why am I
getting too
emotional she still calls my girlfriend
of five more than 5 years still my
friend um which kind of hurts but yeah
sorry 30 seconds left um I my parents
were very supportive I grew up in a
liberal Chicago City based place um they
my dad gave me a pin and my mom said
yeah of course you never liked
boys I came out with a girlfriend when I
was 15 parents were cool uncle's gay
great so my principal added me to my mom
my mom was not happy about it I got
grounded for like a year it was really
awesome and then my girlfriend's parents
who were like strict Catholic Mexican
parents grounded her and pulled her out
of the school I came out as asexual when
I was 16 and so and that broke my
parents heart because they wanted me to
find somebody that I loved so when I was
18 and I came out it was actually a huge
relief to to them so I never had to come
out my mom knew I was gay she asked me
my sister is gay and so yeah it's just
always kind of been a
parent how good is your gayar well let
us know by dropping a comment down below
now let's get back into the
[Music]
video
when we talked about celebrity crushes
she didn't even give us one and she
basically was just like yeah I just came
out because my sister's gay even though
she looked definitely the part and I
really believed her confidence I just
thought okay I think other people are
also going to vote for
her I knew I shouldn't have brought up
the fact that my sister was gay but I
figured my appearance kind of gave it
all away please raise your hand if you
want to continue playing the game
all right that's very clear I want to
ask like what's the gayest thing you've
done to impress a woman because for me I
made matching silk chiffon heart-shaped
pillows for my girlfriend and I because
we both loved muna's silk chiffon song I
was in a relationship like sort of long
distance and I would drive like twice a
week to sispo just like playing music
outside of their house on Valentine's
Day because they broke up with me like
the day before like I've I've had a long
distance partner in Sweden for over 5
years um so we're Limited in what we can
do for gestures what I did do was buy
her a limited edition TCG mount on World
of Warcraft I know that sounds super
nerdy but that's cool uh but it's I
think I spent over $2,000 on it for
supposedly it was going to be for
eventually a marriage gift later down
the line but I want to buy it before it
became increasingly in price but I
couldn't keep a secret so I just ended
up giving it really early so I worked in
editing on a video game series you know
life is strange before the storm so
I yes yes yes and Dana is my personal
Fai so I got autographed from every
single one of the people and gave it to
my now wife it was like the geekiest
thing but yeah she's a gamer um I think
the gayest thing I've done is my best
friend came over best friend at the time
came over and confessed that she was in
love with me and so then we like cried
because I didn't feel the same and it
was just like a really intense
conversation and then I made her dinner
afterwards because I felt bad that she
was crying and then we sat and watched a
movie before she headed home and like
cried you're not really talking about
you being a lesbian you're just kind of
saying like yeah my friend had a crush
on me and I denied her I have a question
are you guys bothered by any particular
celebrity queer baiting I would just go
with the one a lot of people think about
like Billy eyh I would say with the
whole like I wish you were gay kind of
thing like she definitely was one of my
celebrity crushes I went to Coachella
2019 I was like I'm meeting her like
somehow but I think her I would say
Ariana Grande I can't remember the song
something like break up with your
boyfriend cuz of Bor or something at the
end she ends up hooking up with the girl
but like there was no reason for it like
she's never said that I don't know as a
queer person I love representation get
it doesn't have to happen every time but
one of the reasons I didn't come out to
later is because the gay actors that I
loved like they weren't gay in real life
but I was like oh it's an interesting
character choice so I do think it's so
important and for them to be able to
like explore and like without labeling
themselves to be able to explore it but
when it feels fake
like 100% going to turn on the guys or
whatever like do you know which person
out of this group you guys have the
highest doubt in so we can have that
person speak more that way we could
group up our votes into a more ized way
such that if someone says that they
think it's a certain person people are
more likely to vote that person out
because they don't want to be voted out
themselves so they're going to choose
the one that they think will be voted
can I ask about how you met your wife
yes so she's friends with two of my
co-workers um at this I review content
for a children's Programming Network and
so we all had this it's actually funny
it's a Christian Network but every
single person I work with is gay um and
so we had this big lgbtq Christian party
which is pretty unheard of and I met her
there she's 47 she is a lot older than
me that was harder to stomach for my
parents then me being gay but they
absolutely love her now they actually
gave her this is the ring my mom
proposed or my dad proposed to my mom
with and this is what they gave to her
as like we fly confident in you I kind
of have a little bit I wish I could give
you some kind yourself but I won't vote
you out because I don't just because I
have
[Music]
doubt at the end of the day I thought
everyone but Mars seemed more
lesbian to me because Mars was just like
too
pretty that's
crazy I'm feeling very very humbled I
haven't had someone question my
sexuality since I was probably 12
obviously time was against me and the
clock ran out so I wasn't able to answer
and so I left everyone with like a final
impression of oh we sess of Mars which
is valid we have a new rule for future
rounds every time you vote out the wrong
person the prize money will will be cut
in half please raise your hand if you
want to continue playing the
[Music]
game let's do it
okay what is your like favorite thing
and least favorite thing about being a
lesbian like today I would say my
favorite thing is the amount of
Acceptance in the community is it's
lovely um my least favorite thing is
hearing the stories that my wife has
gone through cuz she's 47 um and so she
obviously faced a lot more prejudice I
would say that's sorry say thing uh yeah
the community that involves but also
decentralizing men from your life and
how that's improved my relationships
with other women um also just being in
love with a woman I feel like it's like
not to not to favor but it's like a more
evolved sense and there's such beauty
and being outside and specifically so
outside the patriarchy and then uh
something I don't like I still think
there's issues within the community
within um you know judgments and
inclusion that I really hope that we you
know strive forward with and do more
work on I like being being sort of just
like the opposite of what is like normal
like I feel like that that is so so so
awesome and yeah and I think my least
favorite thing is probably like just
like older men not understanding
especially like out in public spaces
there not being enough spaces like bars
and this and that it's just like you
can't be yourself and it's like you
really don't fit in and it's just you
know I that's what I really really hate
about it there are some a people and in
particular there's some in the lesbian
Community who have said that I can't
call myself a lesbian because I have
been in a relationship with a woman who
happens to be trans and um the last time
I told my coworker about that uh they
said I I couldn't possibly classify
myself as a lesbian if I was willing to
be with someone before surgery or or and
really dig into my um sexual history too
so it's stuff like that but the reason
why I actually came here today was
because I wanted to let trans people
know that you're not an Abomination
you're not a monster uh you are fully
capable of being loved and as as I love
my partner it's nobody else's um
business and you can be you and that's
okay trans women are women if you are a
woman dating a transom you are in a
lesbian relationship don't let anyone
invalidate trans people if anyone has
any doubts about me I'd love to clear it
up I am at this point the most like
straight looking of them all I feel like
two have cried there's no way Maya is
like not a lesbian it's going to be me
would you ever want to get married
someday yeah L I'm working towards it I
I do feel it's a little archaic I do
feel it's a little patriarchal I do
think it's evolving and I do think it's
it's I think it can be done the right
way I think for us like she kind of like
hadn't been with any women before me um
and she's sort of just like the lipstick
lesbian type so um we don't want to just
like conform and just like be just like
a piece of paper
[Music]
yeah it is a four-way tie
a fourway tie I I don't know who voted
me but what are you thinking I've been
the person with the the guard most down
there's there's so much detail in my
stories I feel like maybe we should have
stopped because now all four of us are
kind of turning our head saying maybe
the mole's out already you have 10
seconds to make your argument for why
you should not be voted out fers
typically are have their guard up but
I've been very vulnerable about my live
experience and what I had to go through
so yeah great um I grew up playing
soccer I'm a golden gay never had sex
with a man um serial dater only dated
women and yeah look at me there's no way
I'm going to take it to the camera and
just tell my girlfriend Ally I love you
so much you're the light of my life I'm
going to cry but um I love being lesbian
please like be inclusive if you're
someone who's judgmental stop it knock
it off sort of similar to Alysa and CLA
but I think my emotions with my love of
my wife and the hardships that she has
gone through in her life I think
hopefully make it pretty clear that I am
100% Les man golden gay as well yes one
of the things she said that stood out to
me was she said just look at me I felt
like okay she's dressing
[Music]
up right how could you vote me I am
literally the blueprint there's no way a
straight girl can put on the sheep's
clothing like at all please raise your
hand if you want to continue playing the
game if the lights turn green that means
you have voted out the mole and you win
if the lights turn red that means the
mole is still in the box and you
lose it's it's it's not it's not me when
I count down to one the mole will step
forward and reveal themselves
three
1 oh
[Applause]
cannot I was gagged one of my really
really close friends is a lesbian so was
talking to her a lot she was asking her
friends who are also lesbian and we were
texting and chatting and I was getting
all the Scoops and all the lingo and
verbage that I had no idea existed I do
work in children's content review but
I'm also an actor and an acting coach so
I pulled out some of those water barks I
had a feeling it was morea but that was
completely depleted once Alyssa like
like had loyalty for her but it was
truly so devastating and hard because I
felt like we bonded I'm sorry guys
you're so nice I'm so sorry I feel so
happy that I won I hope I didn't offend
anybody during this process I loved
everybody that I met here um and I feel
bad for lying but not that bad cuz I
just won so lesbians come in literally
all different shapes sizes colors Styles
sexual preferences all of the above as a
lesbian and as a buch lesbian I wanted
to make get very clear that we also have
like a little girl within ourselves and
we're vulnerable I think everyone is
deserving of love and some days you may
not feel like it but try to love
yourself try to love other people and be
kind I hope people who are watching feel
more supportive and know there's
literally no difference between anyone
and a lesbian we're just like a little
bit better always wanted to do
this